let's talk about ukraine and the threat
it's facing from russia
president vladimir putin has been
building up his forces along the border
there are now tens of thousands of
soldiers there nato was alarmed about
russia's military buildup on ukraine's
borders new intelligence suggests the
kremlin is in advance stages of planning
an invasion of ukraine russia the u.s
and other big players have been talking
the people are still nervous any
provocation from any side can be a
trigger for more serious conflict so
what's behind all this to understand the
story here are five things you need to
know
okay so let's start with the basics
here's ukraine it's sandwiched between
russia on one side belarus to the north
and the rest of europe on the other side
and that geography puts ukraine on the
front line in a big power play between
russia and the west
and here's the first thing to know about
what's going on right now it looks like
russia is ready for a fight
all along the border with ukraine there
are around 100 000 russian soldiers
hundreds of tanks and lots of heavy
artillery when i talk to russian
military experts they say that there's
missiles in places where they shouldn't
be and that tanks are fully dressed and
this idiom doesn't mean that the tanks
have lipstick on or their earrings on it
means that they have metal cages on and
they're ready for war we are very very
concerned
but we are not panicking we live with
russian threat for almost eight years
so army is preparing
but definitely you know it's not very
comfortable thing is the relationship
between russia and ukraine has not been
very comfortable for a while now and
that's putting it mildly so here's the
second thing you need to know there's
history between these two this is the
quick version
ukraine and russia were both part of the
soviet union
when the ussr broke up in 1991 they
became separate independent countries
russia was the most powerful country in
the region and still is russia has a
very parochial view of ukraine russia
sees ukraine as its little brother
ukraine was part of the soviet union of
course uh but ukraine has its own
independent identity and part of what
we're seeing here and part of what we've
been seeing since
2013 it is
a so moscow does not want to let ukraine
go so what happened in 2013
well that year kicked off a really
tumultuous time for ukraine it was
tested would it lean more towards its
european neighbors in the west or stay
within russia's orbit
the president back then viktor
yanukovych was about to sign a political
and economic deal with eu but instead he
signed a deal with moscow which a lot of
ukrainians saw as a sign of pressure
from russia
there were huge protests that went on
for months yanukovych was kicked out and
the eu deal was eventually signed by a
new president it was a protest against
attempts to
impose authoritarian model on ukraine
now while all this was happening in
early 2014 president putin made a big
move he sent forces into crimea it's a
peninsula that had been part of ukraine
since the 1950s but russian speakers are
a majority of the population and crimea
always had close ties with russia there
was a referendum in crimea which ukraine
in the west said was illegal but the
people there voted to join russia and
the next thing we knew russia had
annexed crimea the referendum in crimea
was a clear violation of ukrainian
and
international law nobody predicted in
2014 that russia would attack ukraine it
happened but it didn't end with crimea
because things also kicked off in
eastern ukraine we're talking about the
donbass region it's made up of luhansk
and donetsk and is a part of ukraine
that has a big population of ethnic
russians in april 2014 pro-russian
separatists started taking territory and
the fighting became a full-scale war
between them and the ukrainian military
the separatists took control of two
areas they named them the people's
republics of luhansk and donetsk and
said they were independent from ukraine
russia was accused of backing the
separatists with troops and weapons
although moscow has always denied it
eight years later diplomatic initiatives
to resolve the crisis have basically
failed more than 14 000 people have been
killed with 1.5 million forced to leave
their homes the status of eastern
ukraine still hangs on the balance and
the fighting hasn't stopped so that's
the history lesson which helps to
explain where we are now
but then there's nato and that's the
next thing you need to know about with
everything that's happened in the last
eight years ukraine's been getting a lot
of military support from the west it's
now closer than ever to nato and russia
doesn't like it
in washington the signing ceremony of
the north atlantic treaty now remember
nato is the military alliance founded by
western countries after world war ii to
band together against the soviet union
since the collapse of the soviet union
nato's expanded eastward nato now
includes countries that russia sees as
being in its backyard like poland
bulgaria and the baltic states
and russia believes that's a threat to
its own security
it doesn't want ukraine to be next on
the list even though most experts think
that's pretty unlikely anyway
now putin recently made some pretty big
demands which he wants as legal
guarantees among other things he wants
nato to stop any kind of military
cooperation with ukraine and to rule out
nato membership for ukraine or anyone
else and that's a red line we know that
the west will not agree to that
washington can't agree to that russia is
demanding
very very
complicated thing putin is trying not to
uh speak about
russia's proposal as an ultimate
but in fact it's an ultimate so putin's
made those big demands and he has all
those troops on the border but what's
his actual strategy well the next thing
you need to know is that some people
think there's a lot more going on here
people uh want to understand the logic
of putin and it's still not clear one
theory is that this is an elaborate
bluff putin is trying to scare the heck
out of everyone he's trying to scare
biden he's trying to scare the
ukrainians and he's trying to scare
western europe into a deal
another theory is that this isn't just
about nato and military security it's
also about putin's own political
security if ukraine looks like a
successful alternative to his way of
running a country well maybe that makes
putin more vulnerable putin is afraid of
democracy and freedoms and you have
ukraine
on his borders where many russians
speaking ukrainians many russians lives
and it it's it's a free country
so this was interpreted by putin as an
existential threat
to his authoritarian regime if ukraine
succeeds then all of his excuses are
invalid russia and ukraine are are
similar enough that he won't be able to
say uh that democracy is impossible in
russia right okay so here's the last
thing you need to know the current state
of play
the u.s and its allies have been
threatening tough sanctions against
putin if he does go ahead and invade
ukraine they'd be designed to crush
russia's economy and hit its tech and
defense sectors aggression against
ukraine will be met with massive
consequences but some experts question
whether sanctions are much of a
deterrent and think russia is already
making a plan for how it would deal with
them
now the u.s and russia and others have
been holding talks the idea is to calm
things down and avoid a war but no one
seems to be budging we underscore that
for us it's absolutely mandatory
to make sure that
ukraine never
never ever
becomes member of nato russia has to
make a stark choice de-escalation and
diplomacy or confrontation and
consequences one thing's for sure this
is a high-stakes situation for russia
for the u.s and nato and especially for
the people of ukraine the big question
is what's putin's next move
i know him for many many years he will
be tough in the end
he will be tough till the
real red line
and this red line is ukraine
[Music]